[Music]
coaches here
they're expected to be role models
do not screw this up
coach marvin korn is going from the ncaa
to some fancy high school personally i
think it's all a big mistake but
i'm prepared to make the best of it
holly barrett assistant coach
marvin corn any advice these girls going
to lead the world someday
ball in some of them can be a bit much
i'm sorry you chewing gum this is
westbrook we won't respond to my wire
the highway
it's my job to help you improve
i'm gonna teach you my system of
basketball from the ground up smaller
steps but faster
my mom is the whistle really necessary
yes it really is okay then
[Music]
i figured it'd be rough but this is next
level if we all just quit
they fire him i think he wants to be a
good person
when they said you were coming that
meant something i was excited
all i care about is basketball my dad
he sees me playing either at stanford or
ucla it's about making my father proud
after watching you play i truly believe
that we could do something special or
just getting started
oh that'd be a good boomerang do it
again
you're connecting with these girls stop
it
i just wanted to say thank you for
caring
john f kennedy said we do this not
because it is easy but because it is
hard
that was about the moon
if you try your very best
and you have the potential to be great
let's go win a basketball game
[Music]
bye